ce
[Musique]
soir les enfants
allons nounours ne fait pas ça tu sais
bien qu'il ya des enfants qui ont peur
des loups c'est parce qu'ils ne savent
pas que je suis jaloux son de chants
c'est parce qu'ils ont peur des hommes
mais je vais aller surprendre nicolas
est pas propre
richer
de
[Musique]
la mer rouge mieux qu'on aille à
l'accompagnement you des vaches
mots
tu
es bien failli nous faire peur voix
soins
allons vous faites des projets de
vacances
tu sais le nom de nicolas il voudrait la
campagne oui pour voir plein de m pas
seulement des vaches mais aussi des
moutons
[Rires]
[Musique]
des calamars ya rien de tout à la mer il
ya des crocodiles n'y en a pas j'en ai
jamais vu même union main
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
crocodiles sont à lantin la guerre
disait adieu à ses petits enfants dans
ça que ça que dans la poussière il s'en
allait au bape les éléphants à l'époque
on tond les propros l'époque sur les
bordures sont partis dans parlons plus
[Musique]
il agite à ça que dans la poussière
comme s'il était d'avancer triomphant
les animaux devance amin al khair dans
la forêt s'enfuyait tous tremblant
[Musique]
ne sont pas rués sur la terre se
préparait un combat de juan mais près de
la cour est une rigueur le crocodile si
jo tu a subitement
allegro cocon les pros groupon les pros
connus sur les bancs d'une élite son
parti n'en parlons plus
[Musique]
mais oui ils sont pour vous demain vous
pourrez jouer à 20 merci mon gros
crocodile bonne nuit mes chers petits
c'est à la ligne
fait pour
bonne nuit de noces à demain à tout même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aux longs nounours dépêche-toi nous
sommes en retard en potro on sait bien
le musée vous connaissez la chanson du
crocodile au crocodile h en train en
route
donnée les enfants fait pour
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]